serrez vous la halle et serrez vous la
[Applaudissements]
compagne qu'il a été un petit peu lucide
même si je peux comprendre aux fusions
médaille ici par la vidéo mon chéri tu
te rends compte
il ya plein de gens rien dire pire j'ai
tout donné mais l'idée vous voilà allez
on aurait pu parler moi mais ou déjà
hâlées fait c'est la version de doc sais
j'aurais pu devenir pierre moi je sers
pas l'habitude je regrette qu'on serre
la main et sexy ben oui c'est vrai ce
que tu regrettes le dob c'est vrai que
c'était dur quand même ce que tu as fait
cette vidéo mon chéri pour lui parce que
le postulat fait passer pour un mec qui
faisait des sketches syst
[Applaudissements]
cette année toujours une bonne ambiance
entre nous voilà et fait voir bisous
faussement c'est un peu mais bon bien
donc il est dans son monde alors c'est
vrai que voilà moi j'ai accepté mon pote
depuis 15 ans et je laime comme ça et
c'est un mec un vrai gentil tout comme
eric et franchement il n'y a pas de
polémique là-dessus
voilà en brisgau sabia ils ont rigolé
dans cette émission on est là pour
rigoler mon chéri